au delà du football on a tous connu à un
moment donné un grand quelqu'un de
puissant qui abusait de sa puissance et
qui se faisait terrassé par un petit je
parle de goliath et de david mais dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité et dans
nos histoires à nous on l'a connu des
sales petits chefs qui abusé de leur
autorité et auquel on rêvait de demander
grand coup de pied
le pot de terre contre le pot de fer est
une formidable aventure humaine c'est
l'histoire du roman de xavier deutsch 11
qui relate la rencontre d'un petit club
amateur de foot contre l' ac milan une
histoire qui va bien au delà du sport et
qui a séduit les jeunes lecteurs venus
lundi à la rencontre de l'auteur au
collège hélène boucher de
voisins-le-bretonneux votre au livre
mais ça va plus quand même l'histoire ça
m'intéressait le fait que soyons tous à
fond mon football pour arriver à quelque
chose en but précis sont vraiment
intéressés professeurs et collégiens
avaient préparé en amont l'arrivée du
romancier belge question en main ils
sont certes timide les attentive et
leurs questions vont parfois au delà du
roman ce matin on m'a demandé comment
j'avais rencontré ma femme
par quels moyens on m'a demandé de me
prononcer sur la situation politique en
belgique des discussions ouvertes donc
est riche ces rencontres organisées par
les centres de documentation des
collèges et lycées vont se poursuivre
jusqu'à vendredi
après elancourt et voisins le bretonneux
l'auteur devrait investir les
établissements de trappes